[Music]
so dr. diamond you are the go-to doctor
for people like to the Kardashians
Chrissy Teigen this would be relaxing
Katy Perry and her mom I think they
posted in sheet masks hey mom I love you
it's a collagen infusion mass so it just
penetrates collagen we keep it on for
about 15 minutes Katy Perry ever sung
for you I can't say who but last night
late at night we took care of a huge
star and as I was injecting her she was
singing to the table erlik's because she
didn't like the sound of the injection
so I had a front-row seat to like one of
those famous singers in the world Kim
and Kourtney get the PRP micro-needling
skin treatment to boost collagen and
give the face a glow my own blood do you
take them through a secret door how do
you handle celebrity clientele in an
office we have a private elevator many
times many times the to night times and
early mornings that we did at 2:00 a.m.
other celebrity devotees include Kate
Upton Lisa Rinna and Rebecca Gayheart
they took someone in and pressing it in
one procedure that's a favorite of the
famous facial sculpting dr. diamond
injects filler onto the surface of the
bone to create those high cheekbones
like so many celebs have and he says on
average his patients usually start Botox
at age 30
it really can prevent forehead creases
from developing it can prevent neck
bands from forming but what if you don't
have up to 4,500 bucks to spare for
monthly facials or don't want to go
under the knife dr. diamond has these
tips the one conundrum we have is the
skinniest people tend to age the fastest
in the face and the heaviest people tend
to look good in the face but still
boarding smoking Sun avoidance it's
staying well hydrated
you
[Music]